hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
this happened on cnn and you're a good
person you don't watch cnn so you didn't
even know this thing happened a senior
advisor to president biden gene
president biden today pushing back on
suggestions that the u.s economy is in a
recession right now
generally traditionally a recession is
understood to be two successive quarters
of negative economic growth uh and that
is what we're in
i understand that you will tell me that
that's not the official definition but
doesn't this semantic debate risk making
the white house seamless if you're in
denial and out of touch with americans
who are really struggling out there
not at all jake i mean
let's acknowledge
that every single family is the world's
leading expert on how they themselves
are doing and we totally appreciate the
degree that so many americans feel
pinched and squeezed
by the higher prices at the gas pump
even with gas prices down uh you know 75
cents now uh uh you know squeezed at the
grocery uh
line by the impacts of global inflation
on the us we feel that we're not denying
that but i do think it is also
responsible to give people a balanced
view of the state of the economy and
i'll offer you one fact which is in the
history of our country
only last year only in 2021 has there
ever been greater job growth in the
first six months of a year than there
were this year there have been 2.7
million jobs created in the first half
of this year
it is just really common sense that the
second greatest amount of job growth in
a six-month period could not be
consistent with any uh historical
definition of a recession but it's been
two
quarters in a row of negative gdp growth
i mean that is an ugly fact and
traditionally that has been the
colloquial way a recession has been
defined two successive quarters of
negative gdp growth yeah i i agree that
for many people even though it's not the
accurate definition that that has been a
colloquial definition but let's also
remember that in the first quarter when
you actually looked at private sector
growth when you took out some of the you
know trade and inventory numbers you
actually saw the the econ the private
sector economy expand by three percent
so even the first quarter of this year
really was not consistent with any
version of contraction so i just
reminding people that those six months
that people would claim were in
recession are the same six months that
we grew 2.7 million jobs and that only
last year have we ever had that many and
the second closest was 1946 right after
world war ii